some videos like I have to just come up
with the title like last minute but some
videos like with the WNBA when I thought
of it I was like oh what if my title did
don't sleep on the WNBA but in the
picture it's me sleeping yeah I know if
I've seen that I'm clicking on it people
say like oh don't read a book by its
cover but that's it's like you
look at a book cover and it doesn't look
good you're not going to read it yeah
like if it looks interesting and stuff
like that you're gonna at least pick it
up like I have enough confidence in
myself where it's like the content is
gonna grip you I just need you to give
me a chance click on the thumbnail if
you look at my thumbnails they're more
raw like the WNBA one looks like a frame
exactly those are the ones that pop off
like when you look at like the old
school YouTube video it's interesting
it'd be like the most random thumbnails
but they have like 60 million views it
almost feels like it was someone else
capturing it it's like not your video
Someone Else saw this guy sleeping oh
I would challenge you to try it like
yeah probably just raw yeah pause